a lot of people ask me what I do
day-to-day as a web developer one thing
for sure I have to do is a daily
stand-up what's that you say stay tuned
to find out okay so what is the daily
stand-up or DSU for short so basically
it's when everybody on your project or
team gets in a literal circle or they
get on a video chat and each person
takes turn saying what they're currently
working on
it's overseen by an IT PM or project
manager and it allows your team to stay
on the same page on the project and the
structure is simple you basically answer
these three questions what did you do
yesterday what do you plan to accomplish
today and what are your blockers or
issues that you are currently having I
know my first time doing it the SPI was
a little bit scared and if this is
sounding scary to you put in the
comments below why but hopefully I can
give you some examples and we can hash
out those fears now so let me give you
example of something you might say
during a DSU say you had are starting a
new app you grab two tasks from a Kanban
board which I'll talk about later and
your task was to create the home page so
you might say yesterday I created the
home page today I plan to accomplish
applying this styles from the designer
and I have no blockers if you write well
my first time doing a DSU I was super
nervous I sweat a little bit I was
scared but I think by following these
next few tips you will make it
successfully through your first ESU okay
so tip 1 this user usually at the same
time every day so that means you can
prepare for the DSU by writing down
exactly what you're going to say either
the day before or the morning before now
I usually have the know
pad app open on my desktop and I just
write out what I'm gonna say so by time
they get to me all I'm doing is reading
it out and eventually you're gonna ease
to it and so you won't have to do this
anymore but it's definitely a good way
to not be nervous tip 2 don't be afraid
to talk about your blockers now when I
first got started I didn't want to seem
like I was incompetent so sometimes I
wouldn't say what my blockers were but
what wound up happening is I would waste
time try to track down the information
and all I had to do was ask and somebody
could point me in the right direction
and that's what DS user 4 is so that
everybody is on the same page and if you
do have a blocker then people who know
the answer can share that information
with you and you don't have to waste any
time getting the necessary tools that
you need
ok so tip number 3 and the final tip is
to listen to your teammates now I know I
know you might have a lot of meetings
throughout today and listening to people
before you had your coffee might be the
hardest thing to do in the world but
understand that a DSU is not just there
for you to get the information you need
but it's also a chance to share
information that you have so say
yesterday you are working on a problem
and you solved it it was easy but today
somebody is having a similar issue and
now is your chance to step up and say
hey I notice factly what you need let me
help you after the DSU or it may just be
your IT PM saying okay you have ro you
have training that you need to do before
the end of this month I want everybody
to attack you today so we don't have to
worry about it later whatever it may be
this is important time to listen to your
team and to get what you need to push
you through the day if you enjoyed this
video give it a thumbs up I would love
to continue sharing with you some of the
family things that I do as a web
developer and don't forget to subscribe
also I would love to see you on Twitter
or Instagram so take a picture of your
current DSU script and hashtag it coding
like a boss alright see you later